est ce que vous êtes écolo qui acceptent
de ne pas tirer la chasse d'eau à chaque
fois qu'ils votaient wallet pour
économiser de l'eau ça veut dire il y va
quand même à une fois par oui vous
faites c'est la base
oui à quand on fait pipi on tire pas là
lâche maintenant le fait voici et
l'horreur ça fait des économies
faire pipi sous la douche un plus tôt ah
ouais mais jamais fall au balcon non
mais il ya six l'état respecte lui colle
aux chaussures bernard ya un système
maintenant qu'il faut c'est soi ou ça
vous fait la grande commission et vous
appuyez sur le gros bouton une petite
fille mais voilà web et ça c'est quand
on est bernard montiel sarthois partout
où on appuie la chasse d'eau tu en as
toujours un petit peu comme on dit c'est
moi j'ai encore les toilettes turques
800 ya dix ans quand ma mère envie
d'aller aux toilettes elles il va et moi
je l'aï vais juste après les pions tu
[Rires]
sais que si je sais c'est que si ça te
révéler qu'il accepterait de se laver
uniquement deux fois par semaine pour
sauver la planète il s'appelle isabelle
mais non merci
faut arrêter que la légende urbaine il
ya des gens très bien il ya du gp je
prends des douches glacées que ça dure
trois minutes
alors oui on sera mal est fait une
grosse surface donc trois minutes montre
en main
non mais vous vous l'avez donc est ce
que vous seriez prête à vous laver une
faute deux fois par jour deux fois par
semaine
s'il fallait oui bien sûr bah oui même
en laponie tu te l'avais pas beaucoup
[Musique]
disaient laver les mains c'est pas cela
d alors
on vous en aux toiles anciennes halles à
la rivière on la voyait partir quand
même avec un gant comme as en laponie
lui permet de se rend compte que c'est
très très mal conçus en finlande
d'accord merci il n'y a pas de creux
dans le temps mais partout à certains
vallons vous verrez vous verrez ce
voyage en laponie par des centres de 3
which i way n'est pas celle qu'elle a pu
croiser les doigts
une foule du point vous prenez une
douche
combien de fois par jour vous vers
vincent vincent ses propres combinés
joue même les pieds sur la truck ont
donc planché sur la vie de ma mère je
peux manger sur ses pieds à cela c'est
une photo et je sais que j'aime pas les
pires mais lui il a des beaux il ya plus
beaux pieds il a débrayé à 6,6 à toi
dieu bénisse a été réussie de la tête là
d'un acte de foi ils sont très beaux
gosses est le dieu et la finale et hier
il a pris deux diables un autre mec et
ils sont horribles quick dans toi ça va
toi
non mais j'aime bien il ya un truc avant
un concert par exemple ou qui prennent
une douche sais pas pourquoi
ah ouais c'est le truc qui me déstresse
qui aussi avant chaque concert
[Rires]
osez ashecliffe carole tu tu prends toi
tu dois être toi tu sais deux fois par
plus de 12 ans mais j'ai vite deux fois
par jour mais c'est vrai que j'aime bien
le matin quand je me lève et je sais
quand tu rentre le soir si on bâtit oui
mais c'est pas bon non mais je mets ça
pour le coup c'est pas très écolo mais
j'éteins la lumière je fais le tri
sélectif
je marche évite de prendre la voiture
cimpor
je mets la casserole pour le couvercle
pour faire bouillir l'eau des petites
choses bernard montiel ou deux fois par
jour le matin mettais pas être pas la
tête comme ça non non non mais parce que
c'est vrai que c'est dommage parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas la vida hymne
deux fois par jour je peux passer vous
une fois par jour et j'ai acheté un
petit sablier qui veut notre le piton
donc cinq minutes de douche je sais
après avoir être au village cabinet mon
frère il atteint sablier il a un mec de
petite taille qui tapent à la porte
[Rires]
avant du bon goût deux fois par jour une
fois chez moi une fois la piscine parce
que j'y vais quasiment faite à la
piscine tous les goûts donc je me sers
de la nouvelle corde
[Applaudissements]
vous avez commencé parce que c'est
arielle dombasle qui disait qu'elle a de
tout temps la piste je me suis dit que
j'allais être comme elles vont
s'arracher gibellina croll a fait une
belle rencontre à la piscine
bref vous avez déclaré dans une piscine
de stars y avait dany boon qui étais et
j'ai vu gad elmaleh ya pas très long à
voile et punir s'avéra ségolène royal
alors ah ouais ségolène royal j'ai raté
la rumeur nous de ma vie photos du ciel
ségolène royal s'était juste après sa
défaite à l'élection les renault que
devient ségolène royal ou est elle je la
vois arriver en maillot de bain léopard
à ma piscine non elle se met sur le
transat j'étais dans l'eau mois elle des
prix un journal c'était le paris match
avec la couverture de sarkozy ont suivi
cette photo elle aurait fait de leur
bébé devra tout donner
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
trois malades dans un fond d'eau j'ai
trouvé la technique de m dos rempli la
baignoire est un tout petit fond d'eau
et je me lave avec comme ça alors vous
vous concerne dégoûtez pas un bonbon
voulons c'est non et échoue c'est long
c'est vous signale que deux fois par
jour les dermatos disent que ça n'est
pas mes doigts et mes deux fois par mois
ça commence à venir
on vous adore quand même jour glace sont
peu de salles et sympathique
je veux dire ici vraiment à paris s'il
ne peut pas vous sentir
moi je vous kiffe et c'est pas vrai cela
vais tous les jours on l'affaiblît
j'étais tout le temps dans sa chambre
avait ou pas oui parce qu'avec un rôle
il j'ai squatté dans leurs bras alors je
m'en foutais totalement caroline ces
messieurs vous et pour vous que j'étais
là oui vous à l'arraché plus écolo de
tous puisque ce fait les plans douche
donc on est deux ou trois dedans vous
l'avez fait couler en plus longtemps ben
non je veux même pas des
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez oui mais ouais et stoppait excuse
moi non mais ici on est fâché avec sa
vie sexuelle mais pas tu veux dire c'est
pas c'est pas une photo tu adverse un
diaporama toi